[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
tonight the music seems so loud
i wish that we could lose this crowd
hey babe it's better this way
we hurt each other with the things we
want to say hey babe what's up babe
speaking of hurting each other so i got
a seven-day-old daughter yeah doctor
told us
i said hey can we go to little july 4th
bbq she said absolutely not the
pediatrics she said
during the pandywandy if god forbid your
your seven day old
daughter got a fever just to rule out
cover anything else we'd have to give
her a spinal tap
so since you know what we'll stay home a
spiny tea a spot
a tap to give her an s tap they gave her
an s type oh my god how does that work
on a baby that's the size of a i don't
even want i don't even want to know i
have no idea all i know is i'll tell you
this
i haven't slept in about eight nine days
i'm delirious my fitness pal app
yeah out the window i
haven't even you're not looking at it
so she uh in nine days eight nine days
i'm not lying to you i've gained
13 pounds because the gluttony
no no sal the way that i've been eating
you gained a pound and a half a day
do you understand cause let me tell you
what happened you're getting a half a
pound every eight hours
let me tell you what i just did even
right now on the way here i called you i
said hey you're ready to go he said give
me a few more minutes i said no problem
i went down the street to pizzeria
i ordered three grandmas a regular slice
and a chicken parm garlic knot with a
diet dr pepper
three grandmas a regular and a chicken
pump no you didn't
it's in the front seat of my car oh that
right now that's massive yeah
yeah and then this morning oh and then
also by the way i just want to give a
quick
shout out i want to give a quick shout
out to americano cafe
on uh on staten island americano cafe i
don't know if you've ever been there
americano cafe
i i went in for an iced coffee and i
also got a pound cake
and the lady said she said would you
like to heat it up i said no i'm okay
she goes i really can't let you eat this
unless i heat up the pound cake
what does that mean i said what do you
mean is it stale and she had to make it
soft i said what do you mean you can't
let
she goes trust me the difference between
eating this heated up
and not heated up is insane
i said to her hold on okay good i said
to her wait a second
like you're telling me it's a world of
difference she goes come here
takes out a piece of the pound cake says
try this breaks it
i'm not making this up brakes are off
with her hands no gloves and i just was
she broke you off a piece
she broke off a piece of that pound cake
bar yeah cold ice cold said taste that
yeah so i taste it forget the fact that
she just used to bare hands it doesn't
matter
i said okay i say it's pretty good she
goes give me 25 seconds
puts that piece into the toaster oven
hands it back to me
she goes now try it i took a bite it was
the best piece of pound cake i have
ever had in my life had i not heated it
up
i would have never known that i am now
going to make it
effort in my life to every day go to the
americano cafe
inside i don't know if it's the urbia
the derby oh the herbie
the irby inside the urby derby on staten
island
to go get that pound cake from the
lovely woman working on the counter i
don't know her name
she was a fantastic person she told me
he got that pound cake she said it was
next level and it was next level
and i ate that pound cake which give or
take 350 cows
black iced coffee said i'm good i'm
feeling good black guy's coffee
i go black iced coffee who
what do you mean who who's coffee black
iced coffee
am i the guy at herbie who no no black
iced coffee you thought i was saying
black iced coffee for a moment i did yes
wow black iced coffee well you ready for
this black guy's coffee well how about
this
i thought the guy that worked there made
you oh no a black iced coffee black iced
coffee
black iced coffee black iced coffee i
told you about the story with me and did
i tell you about did i tell on the
podcast
because you were talking about a woman
and you had a woman's pound cake and you
were like then i got a then i got the
black iced coffee to be honest with you
if we ever got to the coffee business
black iced coffee not a bad name for our
brand yeah black iced coffee
yeah and black iced coffee it'll be me
and you black face on the thing
10 30 right after an all brand new
episode of impractical jokers
thursdays are for the baby just get
black friends to invest with us
that's what yeah because that's it
that's it that's easier and more
authentic
yes yeah the average adult
weight fluctuates up to five or six
pounds per day sal
i know i do it all comes down to what
and when you eat drink exercise and even
sleep so i mean get no sleep
no exercise have have okay
ask me when the last time i had a
vegetable was when was the last time you
had a vegetable i don't know
you don't even know i don't even you
gotta have greens your body's gonna let
me tell you something right now
i'm with you all the way to be fair to
you oh i threw out my
disco ball i threw out my uh my fitness
pal app a long time ago
i'm i'm trying to rekindle with it now
hey we just added tickets
providence rhode island philadelphia
pennsylvania we have opened them up go
to chrisdcomedy.com those tickets were
sold out forever
but we added seats capacity uh no more
christy half capacity now it's chrissy
full capacity
go to chrisdcomedy.com providence july
22nd to the 24th and uh uh philadelphia
pennsylvania august 18th to the 21st
go to christy comedy.com that tt jerry's
phone is ringing he will be there
but he can't leave state lines but once
he's allowed to he's going to start
coming to my shows here's what i'll tell
you and i mean and i
genuinely mean this yeah because first
of all obviously you know and the fans
obviously the hey babe no and homeless
people love you guys by the way we're
looking right at you
and homeless pimp has texted this to me
privately out of nowhere for no reason
you are you're a hottie with a body and
we know that
but i just want to tell you i just want
to tell you
that you're a guy you're a guy who i
feel you look good anyway when you've
been 20 pounds over it's fit when you've
been 20 pounds
under it's fair that's sweet enough i
don't i look and i see i hate myself
well no but that's what we all do
i'm a guy right now i'm just about
i would say six to ten pounds away from
getting the fat face and being now
noticeably
out of shape fat feeling disgusting
that's impossible
you're just in the shape of your life
it's gone quick
you you fluctuate that fast so as do i i
gain like maybe in the last two
two months i've gained up over 10 pounds
probably
and i lost two months before that i lost
to 10. i
have fluctuated on camera even in my
life um let me think about this since
the show started
i have fluctuated 40 pounds up and down
like five to four times
really yeah yeah i just it's just it's
just what happens i
i get into a mindset i lose lose weight
i get to a certain goal i'm like
whatever and i just
and then i don't i don't look at my
weight again until it bothers me again
and i just
and i kind of do that i've done that my
whole life like ping-pong back and forth
but i'll
but let me ask you this but are you but
does when your weight goes up
does it bother you to the point where as
soon as you wake up that day you're like
i can't believe how disgusting i feel
and then your day
the tone of your day is set negatively
from the moment you wake up 100 accurate
really yeah or like you'll look at
yourself in the mirror no shirt and be
like and almost be
terrified at what you see like you can't
imagine
like how bad it is a hundred that's how
i feel yeah that's how i feel about
myself i'll avoid mirrors
that's how i feel but but then how do we
get out of that because it's not eating
right because i i can't i've already
kind of given up now on the fact that
i'll ever be able to get healthy
i try to eat right and it's and
sometimes it doesn't take
and then it takes like months and months
what's the most you've evolved went up
and what
have you ever lost in your life okay so
at one point at one point in 2014
in uh uh january february of 2014
80 yeah 80 yeah a.d i went i was 256
pounds okay but you're a tall guy
but 256 is 256. sure you know it's it's
it's just
actually i have i don't know i knew you
then yeah did i know you've been
wait uh yeah i'll show you a picture of
me and then i'll send this to you pimp i
was 256 pounds well
you know you would never know that
you're not you don't feel confident
because you you are dressed like a blue
leopard
today yeah well i want this is like a p
almost like a peacock type of shirt see
i
like i i walked in you were just a
vibrant burst of energy that came
through my throat is this too much you
think this is
no but i'm saying it's not indicative of
the way you feel inside
because because i thought this was a
good fourth of july
sure i love it you walked in it's the
first thing i noticed
i think it's a nice reflection of your
personality okay but you're telling me
how you feel
inside and that's not what that shirt is
saying yeah because because
inside inside i feel here i'll show you
a picture of myself when i was 256 and
this is what i
feel like right now i don't know if i
necessarily look like this guy right now
but i
feel like this guy big time right now
oh wow okay i see the weight there yeah
yeah but that's also the face shape can
we get this on the screen pip if i text
you now okay what is this a picture of i
don't
so this was this was a picture that tmz
took of me and posted on their website
i swear to god we got one of my friends
got this off
that's a bad angle i don't know if you
look but it does it does look heavier
than you are now for
certain and this was me right before
let's throw that one up too yeah yeah
and then this was me this one
in your phone shut up mike bushetti
um so so so i was 256 yeah uh january or
february of 2014
a.d by by august
or i'm sorry yes by august because i met
jasmine
delilah's uh mother um uh my girlfriend
in
in
in in july of 2014 she was pregnant told
me she was pregnant in
august early september of 2014. okay
um by that time 2 56
january february by that time i was 210.
i had lost 46 pounds
is that the most we've ever lost yes in
in four or five months but then as soon
as my daughter was born
in may of 2015 so about a calendar plus
year later
i was back up to about 240. that's
that's my that's your yoyo
all the time let me ask you a question
what did you do to drop to 46
boxing yeah boxing huge
second thing i did i cut out 100 dairy
i didn't worry about bread i just ate no
i'm talking about
is dairy is dairy as bad as sugar and
carbs i just
what hap i don't think so no but i just
said if i don't put so anything that had
dairy cake has
you're just sucking down dairy at every
turn it's like you couldn't you couldn't
get enough for dairy like if you had a
car
that was older and you didn't mind
putting a bumper sticker on it would you
have a bumper sticker that said i break
for dairy
yes i would say i would say i would say
my my cells no longer break down for
dairy i'm lactose free i would say like
for example
and that didn't mean that your cells
break down i thought we're talking about
stickers when they're like i break for
like it means like
full stop like i i think that's what it
means right i didn't mean to have a
bumper sticker that talked about like
whether your enzymes break down that's
right
but but still they didn't break down
dairy no but so you would like
were you lactose intolerant no i wasn't
i just thought i felt like what happened
was i saw a documentary i don't remember
which one but about how milk when milk
comes out of a cow because it's so
pumped up with hormones and all that
it's just
blood clots it's just blood clots in pus
blood clots and pus and then when you
get the actual milk
it's all synthetic white dye chemicals
but it's blood and pus is what you're
drinking
so then i went there for the almond milk
but then i was like oh but
so i was like okay i'm good just
drinking almond milk but then when blood
and pus
you know the milk that they use in dairy
for ice creams and cheeses on pizzas and
cheeses on cold cuts
is all the pus filled i know i'm i don't
know
our country who has a strong
constitution yes happy fault happy
fourth
um but but but but yes see when a cow is
infected 90
of the somatic cells in her milk are
neutrophils uh inflammatory immune cells
form pus
so per spoonful the average somatic cell
count us milk is
one one million one hundred and twenty
thousand so it is 100
plus what you're drinking that they so
but but so what i would do when i lost
to the weight is even when i ordered a
pizza i would get pizza i would take the
cheese off i
never got ice cream unless it was almond
milk i never got yogurt unless it was
almond milk i completely got out of
everything that had to do with your
wheat though
it i started to drop all this well
because you didn't like it just because
it was pus
but by virtue of eliminating those foods
you lost weight
in concert with that exactly because now
what are you eating instead of eating
cause now uh uh a dessert treat for me
wasn't an ice cream it wasn't two car
valanches which i ate last night last
night i had two carvel answers one
reese's carvalhan from carvel
carver what carvalhan google it
it's the best thing carter is that some
new product no no no no no no no
this has been for years oh it's almost
like a blizzard a carvalanch
an avalanche it's carvel's answer to the
dq blizzard
wow they really i guess you got to do
that they're like this is who we're
going up against you have to have a
similar name you have no choice that
seems like it could be in territory of
maybe a little bit of a lawsuit
i'm not going to speak about it though i
don't want to speak i don't want to look
out of turn right now i don't want to
speak out of tournaments
if you ask if you put a gun to my head
the best ice cream i think back to your
bucket is baskin robbins but there's not
one near me
yeah so i go car valentine's 31 flavors
right absolutely
and they let you taste test which carvel
doesn't they say they do they don't
really at least the one on third avenue
86 street in my neighborhood they don't
carvel if you're watching and we know
that you are
yeah let's let's let's start making it
uh with the with the samples and just
while you have it open just while you
have it open
i just want to give a quick shout out to
briars you can suck my ass
i don't like why that's the opposite of
a shouty yeah
that's a non-shaft non-shouty if you if
you right you gotta you got problems
with briars i got problems with briars
problems with bryce i don't like briars
i don't like briars you don't like them
you don't like them as people you don't
like their branding you don't like what
the company stands for you don't like
the taste
i don't like you don't like the variety
of variety they don't have enough
variety okay we hit on it
they don't have enough variety they got
your chocolate they probably have your
vanilla
they probably have they have the truth
they got the what's it called
napoleon napolitan napolitan napoleon
napoleon bonaparte neapolitan neapolitan
neapolitan no that's a pizza
yeah see briars i also feel i don't feel
sophisticated i don't i feel low class
ryers was
my family's ice cream of choice when i
was growing up
well that says a lot about you to me sal
i i always thought it was like
good but no no no no no no nothing
against
well but there's some [ __ ] ice cream out
there let me walk it back
i i know i got a little hot and have you
a prize i did not mean to i'm on very
low sleep as i've said no no no no
if you need to let bryce have it you
turn to camera one and you let bryce
have it
breyer's breyers briars listen
i know what i just said about you and i
said you can suck my ass and i don't
i don't necessarily mean that
i'm not saying i love your products if
you do i support you
i but for you to for me to say that i
would like the people the good people
that do work at bryce the ceos of brides
to get on the knees and suck my ass
is not right and i didn't mean that you
overshot that i overshot that
if you're asking me what i think you can
do better
yeah is then i what i think you can do
better is
add a little bit more variety class up
the joint a little bit
be a little bit more sophisticated a
little bit tighter with your product
because if you're looking for in an ice
cream
efficiency and unfortunately if you look
back and through history
if you look back through history you
know take it or leave it these people
i'm not saying they always made the
right choices most of the time they made
the wrong choices
but if you're looking for efficiency if
you look for efficiency
a tightly run ship and putting up good
numbers
then you have to go to the germans and
you have to go haagen-dazs yeah
everybody knows that
everybody knows that but do you think
bryce thinks they're even competing
hitler's ice cream that's right it is
is that was it around during him
if you're listening and you we know that
you are uh we we don't know that this is
speculation we're going to find out
right speculation but
we will put you on blast if it's true i
got news for you i got i got about
i got about a a quarter of a lot of
vodka in uh in this christmas
cheetos handmade vodka and i got and i'm
on low sleep so i apologize if i'm
coming out
what do we got oh the fuhrer cake an
apple cake strong with nuts and raisins
had to be baked each day and left out
every night he was also partial to
chocolate biscuits and scones with tea
which he would drink from a nymphenburg
porcelain cup on paper
on paper if you didn't know anything
about this like i'd hang out with this
guy
oh just if you're judging a man by his
treats
i mean we're having a good time lesson
learned do nev never
never judge a man by his favorite treats
never he could be
the worst person ever birthed yeah birth
wars made on living with the fuhrer he
loved midnight cake
linen linens and tea from porcelain
china cups
there you go okay well
haagen does yeah let's get back to
haagen-dazs but you know who do you
think haagen-dazs number one competitor
is
i mean volkswagen joe derose is going to
die
i mean everybody's doing taste buds now
okay
yeah yeah yeah oh they're doing what's
pretty far they do it in a
competitive way
oh jenny's honestly shout out jenny's uh
now this isn't jenny's by the way sent
joe derosa a six pack of pints
and never sent me them which is a little
bit unfair they had a cream cheese
everything
bagel ice cream that i've been really
wanting to try cream cheese everything
bagel ice
cream everything bagel with cream cheese
yeah yeah you know what goes good with
that
shower together peanut butter go go
peanut.com and pick up the no pressure
i think that we sold so much peanut
butter that we probably should have just
sold our merch first
because i think every single fan of ours
went out and bought the peanut but not
that they shouldn't
yeah but i just mean whoo i think that
did well because yesterday i did a
slight perusal
yeah i was on like the the gram yeah
instagram yes
and uh and i saw and i just saw like a
flurry
of the saratoga purchases like but like
like dozens and dozens and dozens
yeah and i was like i love it yeah i
love it it's supporting supporting them
to almost a small business makes you
think though and charity yeah yes that's
true
what makes you think though should we
have just opened our own peanut butter
cup yeah we should have got
saratoga and listen hey we we love
saratoga but you know listen
we may open up our own peanut butter
company we certainly are going to open
up our own coffee company black iced
coffee that's right black guys
that guy's coffee speaking of black guys
got to give it up for tom brady
for winning the super bowl oh the bucks
they won that super bowl what they did
down in tampa bay yeah was exquisite
this year
um congrats to you one of the best
players i would think of all time but
you
can't mention the bucks without
mentioning patrick and mahomes and the
chiefs they got a solid young team they
got big things ahead of them yes they
already have one under their belt and
they really showed up and it was a
really nice game love it
how about this speaking of competition
guess who has some competition now
kane tanaka our good old ass friend
friend friend of the pod friend of the
pod came through the pod mrs kane tanaka
sitting there someone just said that
it's not kane
like there's a i guess was she korean is
she korean
japanese japanese because it's a
japanese uh i guess
pronunciation like uh maybe it's
kane kane tanaka you know
okay i mean i'm reading it you know i
apologize let's get his name right then
because we have a new guinness book a
world record all the way from puerto
rico
emilio flores marquez oldest living
person male
he's identifying as male his age is 112
years
326 days this breaks the previous record
held by romania's dimitro komenescu
who died at 111 years 219 days young
wow wow so this guy's 112. look 112.
that's a great old shout out 112. shout
out 112.
you know do it better shout out mace by
the way i hope you get your money yeah
uh can you scroll up a little bit
uh it looks like he does not know he's
what he's holding though but god bless
him god love him
amelia still has a fashion sense
well because i was going to say at least
in this picture this face he looks like
he's
been dead for quite some time if i'm
being honest with you
this picture looks like a dead body that
they dressed up and put a plaque in here
it looks like we need photo proof we
need some type of proof because he looks
propped up
yeah mark has all this amongst 11 kids
married for 75 years wife died in 2010
so she lived a long time as well
underwent surgery at 101 always an honor
to celebrate these remarkable human
beings oh okay
oh my god i i wonder how many couples
make a 75-year wedding anniversary
i would say i guarantee you like it's
got to be like
pimp i don't know what you googled for
that what's the
what's the oldest living marriage what's
the oldest living marriage
okay here we go you ready for this but
how long were they married
it doesn't make sense grammatically or
or
in a vocabulary sense uh with a broken
heart 105 year old waldorima quinteros
said goodbye to her 110 year old husband
cesar mora
who died thursday at his home in ecuador
the couple has received a guinness book
over
longest lived marriage combined age oh
oh oh
oh so their cumulative ages added up
has been the longest ever you know at
214 you know what's great about you is
you would you know obviously i know you
and the fans know you but if i didn't
know
that you had any like spanish in you
because you have spanish in you but the
way you just said quinteros was like a
white
irish fireman yeah just learning spanish
for the first time well
you know what i don't want to do i don't
want to do that thing with people like
uh
you know uh yeah do it do it how
annoying people do it yeah go back to
the name go back to
doing hilarious
but so i read it read it read it read
read that how like annoying people
well that's not where's the where's the
name where's the original uh
isn't it uh with a broken heart 105 year
old
valdari maquinteros said goodbye to our
110 year old
cesar mora who died thursday at their
home in ecuador
yeah i was like i did it like you have
like in spanish class yeah
when they're like no hablo and glace
yeah like i remember my
in spanish class my boy pat finnegan
yeah mr santos how do you fly balls
patty fly balls shout out mr santos
artificial mullein high school when it
was miss
pat finnegan's time to read we would be
like the anticipation we would be like
almost passing out from the laughter
which it all did because he would
he knew it and he would just kind of be
like yo soy patrick
la penguino estoy like you know
and then mr santos would be like that's
very good patrick that's very good but
we should try you know try this try that
and he could just never get it and dude
we would be i mean dying yeah
dying laughing that's that's literally
one of the only the only real memories i
have from high school
are me catching uh two teachers
hooking up in the in the cafeteria not
having sex
not having sex fully making out yep okay
but were they a public item or was it
did you did you find them making out and
no one even knew about their
relationship there was always
speculation that they were an item there
was always speculation they were having
an affair
to do it on school prop yeah i walked
into the cafeteria i walked to the
cafeteria
after out like you know 3 30 which is
after i was in high school
i walked in they were having an
after-hours party after i was 3 30 i
walked in
because i was like staying to go to the
gym or driver's ed or something like
that
but 3 30 i walk in and i saw them
kissing and i got so nervous i dropped
my beeper
like i remember i burned my hands and my
beeper fell
and broke through a million pieces and
my mother couldn't get in touch with me
and it was a whole big thing i'd say mom
did they see you see that yes
yes and the i forgot it's not on you
though no no
they like he was like what are you doing
here what are you doing i was like oh
i'm sorry i need to go to the beginning
maybe i could ask you the same question
yeah what's going on on hand mrs
petrella yeah i was like
yeah does what does your wife think
you're doing here sir because they
weren't they were unfair so i remember
that it was an affair
yeah they weren't they weren't they were
married to other people but everybody
always knew that they were hooking up oh
man that's a crazy thing second thing i
always remember
pat finnegan always laughing all of us
laughing with mr
santos the third thing i remember from
high school 9 11. all right
those are the things you were in high
school 911 i was a senior in high oh wow
i was like in the workforce graduated
out of college like nine to five
no i was this [ __ ] senior in high
school the teacher came in i'll never
forget mr diorio he said boys
both twin towers just fell down there's
an astronomical chance
if any of your parents work in the city
they're probably dead i swear then he
took a pause i swear to god then he took
a pause
he goes let's talk about the
revolutionary war
it was september and we were learning
about america from day one
until now so it was september 11th we
had just started school a week ago so
the chapter rome was colonial america
revolutionary war it was literally as
that
took maybe a three second pause that's
crazy he goes let's talk about george
washington in the minute men
so open everyone i'll never forget that
wow yeah and i might do it was bad yeah
i remember because my mom worked and i
told you this my mother worked in the
second tower yeah yeah but she
survived thank god survived um but um
but um those are the three things those
are the three things
three things that i remember you you
just reminded me that i remember
a couple a teaching couple hooking up in
my school
we didn't see them necking but
uh but it was uh it was the art teacher
and
one of our like social studies teachers
and his name was billy billy bob i think
his name was right that was his first
name
and he had a mustache and he wore
pleated slacks yeah and this art teacher
used to wear like like you ever see the
episode of seinfeld with the puffy shirt
she used to wear like puffy shirts yeah
yeah but it was like
they were very puffy yeah and they were
very very thin and light
and the sun used to come through and you
would see her bra
yeah underneath the puffy shirt yeah and
sometimes she would turn
and the shirt was so billowy that the
space between the first and second
button would buckle
right and it'd be like a tunnel right in
through here
and everyone the best everyone it was so
apparent
that it was deemed that she was doing it
purposefully i believe she was
i believe at this point with with the
amount of of of
a female teacher that have sex with the
students and get turned on by that i
would have to imagine she was
now looking back doing it on purpose
could be 100
i'll never forget i graduated from when
i graduated from eighth grade uh
our seventh grade teacher who i don't
know i have a vibrant memory of this i
don't know why you go eighth grade
graduation where'd you go to dinner uh
lunch after
uh i don't recall it might have been the
colonnade diner
because uh for every like graduation and
funeral in my family for like 20 years
we went to the colonnade dining for
literally my daughter's christening we
went to the colony
we went we got her christened at saint
charles church and then we went to the
colonnade diner
i also did stand up at the colonnade
diner no
you didn't know you did the loony bin
comedy club on staten island was in the
back of the colonnade diner for like
four years
oh my god i did like a guest set there
when i was going to visit my father
before he moved to tampa but he didn't
tell me
that is unbelievable what kind of crowd
was that you know the same people that
would be at the loony bit the looney
people that would be at the colony yeah
say people to be the colony just yeah
you know
you're world war ii vets you know off
duty sanitation workers
[Laughter]
necking meaning to kiss embracing caress
was first documented
in 1825 wow referred to as necking
because the affection
uh is done above the neck listen it
makes sense
one time when i was in college out at st
joseph's college
we used to go my friends you know i
played basketball for them division
three so it's not like you counted or
anything yeah don't sell yourself short
all right but still okay
but we would but we would go we would do
like battleships
you know just immature software stuff i
never heard of that until
harold and kumar so battle shits would
it be is it the same thing like me
and you would go into stall-to-store and
we would just you know i don't know if
that was real i saw it was in harold and
kumar
the original one and the two girls play
it yeah and while he's hiding in the
and he hears them so i was like is that
a real thing
so i go in to one day and see and i'm
i'm in there and then
yeah and it's so gross and i could just
see somebody's shoes and i thought and i
was thought it was my boy ricky who's on
the team and i go ricky and he goes he
goes yeah buddy
and i go battle shits and he goes okay
like but but reluctantly and i was like
oh whatever so i go and i'm just ripping
an iphone
like i'm talking about like ripping it
and it's like just crate
like that was the point it's like you
have to wait till you have to like
almost like because i used to drink
nutriments all the time because
i get jacked off them but they just gave
me explosive rampant diarrhea yeah
so i was it was one of those it was a
nutrient annuity [ __ ] we used to call it
and i was literally i mean going like
and i was like come on ricky come on he
was like he was like i'm trying buddy
he was like i'm trying buddy i'm trying
and i'm talking about ripping it
off like it was splattering off the
backsplash of
like like a disgusting 18 19 year old
disgusting thing
pulling my pants wipe my ass i knock on
the door i'm like you lost that one son
like you know like just a hit on the
door like blah blah blah goes yeah yeah
man he goes i'll see you later so i go
downstairs not i don't
i i didn't think anything of it other
than i just destroyed him with battle
shits
you know 45 minutes go by he comes down
he goes bro
i was getting a blow job from deborah in
the stall when you walked in he goes
literally there was a girl in there with
me
i was trying to get a job during class
he goes we were
she was dying almost gagging in the
corner because you were screaming battle
shits
and ripping rampant diarrhea he was like
i didn't know what to do because she
couldn't leave the stall
because you would have seen her feet and
i was literally in the middle of that
and i had no clue
that you were in there doing it that's
why i wasn't playing along and i was
like oh
my god and then literally it was one of
those unspoken things
where i knew that deborah was in there
and i knew that deb
and debra knew that i knew so we just
never talked to each other again
shout out debra shout out debra i
thought you were going to say you went
downstairs ricky was down there
no and you didn't know who was in the
store he was getting a blog
wait archbishop malloy was co-ed st
joseph's colle this was a college thing
i was in college already this is st
joseph's college oh so that kind of
shenanigans were happening in college
one of the teams like in like in the in
the in the building in the classroom
that's
that's pretty uh our college was like
high school it was like a high school
our college
the first couple years then then you
start to get a little bit more mature
but in the beginning it was
it was uh yeah that con that my college
experience was you know
was crazy like that you know there was
always rumors going around in my high
school that there was a
one of the spanish teachers also had
given someone oral and they said there
was an
actual photo floating around of it
female spanish teacher
yeah gave somebody oral interesting you
never know if it's true or not you know
it's just like
there's these rumors yeah no i i i
i know at other high schools of people
who hooked up with the teachers
like confirmed did you ever do [ __ ] like
we had a vermin day in our school
what does that mean like it was like a
day when all the kids decided to
to cause chaos together you know about
the chaos christy chaos tuesdays 11 am
eastern time
we would like uh like whoever would
partake that day we would say oh today's
vermin day and then you bring in
a rodent a rat a raccoon a lot of rats
and uh you know and then you at a
certain time everyone would release them
and so there would just be rodents
running around and like the teachers
would freak out and everything had to
shut down
yeah i was going to say this wasn't a
sanctioned school event no
it was just among the students we had
rice day where everyone just bought in
like a five pound bag of rice kept in
the locker
and then in between classes everyone
came out and at the same exact time
wednesday lockout cut the bags open
spilled the rice out
and then put everything and went back to
class and now we never the teacher would
walk into the hall and it'd be like
three four inches of rice for like 200
feet no
never did that ever i mean it's
hilarious never not we didn't it was it
was
all boys so that's probably why we did
it no i i was all boys high school
okay well i don't but the thing is
really
with with because i was a senior during
9 11 right after
like how tightly wound security was all
over the country that it was so
like there was almost like no fun going
on senior year
like the year before they did like the
year before i remember in archbishop
lloyd they released pigs
and they they had released three pigs
and it was but they numbered them one
two and four
and so they're like they were looking
for three and they never found
it was like a whole thing yeah they did
one two and four
listen one of the most fun things i like
to do is have a circle jerk in
squarespace
yes yes yes absolutely squarespace one
of the most fun things i love to do is
just build websites
yes build them you ever just sit there
building a website in
your glory squarespace
if you're not by the way i couldn't do
it before squarespace no are you kidding
me
no i didn't build anything before
squarespace one platform it's an
e-commerce it's got domains
marketing tools analytics and the ease
of ease of use
are the things that i'd like to
highlight and the things that
squarespace themselves have highlighted
on this ad copy
as for us to say things that really
stick out why squarespace is the best
it's professional portfolio designs it's
display projects in customizable
galleries
and add password-protected pages to
share private work
with clients homeless pip users
squarespace iu squarespace
sal uses squarespace i've used
squarespace to build a no pressure
website
to use squarespace to build a new place
i mean look at this you can't get more
organic than that
absolutely head to go to checkout
squarespace.com hey babe for a free
trial and when you're ready when you're
ready to launch
use the offer code hey babe to save ten
percent off your first purchase of a
website or domain so just go
to squarespace.com hey babe don't even
feel fresh feel no pressure
that's right network turns on
squarespace turn your cool idea into a
new website
well i just want to start off i just
want to start off this ad by saying this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you know what
this is about i know what this is about
online
professional counseling from people that
are authorized
and educated to do so it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help no it's
professional counseling it's done
securely
you can start within 48 hours okay broad
range of experts so you're not
you're not limited to the people in your
local area and it doesn't matter and
broader range of experts broad range of
things they can talk about it you can go
from anywhere from just having a little
if you're a person who just has a little
little anxiety better help is the place
for you if you're a person that's been
incarcerated because you decapitated
your grandparents
better help's got a therapist for you
worldwide prestige worldwide babe
you log into your account anytime you
get timely thoughtful responses
uh and you can schedule a weekly video
or phone session so it's really really
really cool
easy and they got the special we got the
special offer hey babe listeners you got
10
off your first month all you have to do
is go to betterhelp
that's betterhelp help.com
hey babe you're going to get 10 off your
first month
go talk to someone mental health is a
serious issue better help is the best
place to do it
go go do it and uh you know if if you'd
like
email the podcast what you talked about
with your therapist and we'll
make fun of it on an episode yeah and
we'll take the hippocratic oath before
in the florence nightingale syndrome and
the night
and then the night what was it the the
hippocratic oath of the nightingale poem
the night yeah he had to watch you
rewind the episode on the episode
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 off your
first month and i remember this whole
thing like if you see the number three
pig like this is an animal
but like they have it was the whole
point there was only everything the
first week of school the seniors used to
try to sell the kid the freshman
pool passes uh there's no pool no pool
yeah i guess that's a thing that's an
old boy's school thing yeah yeah
yeah my school they covered the main
staircase in baby oil
and everyone got hurt everybody that's
that's insane
you could die yeah people got really
hurt like teachers fell down the stairs
yeah there was like a concus like bad
concussions
i believe it dude people got thrown out
of school yeah honestly for that i would
i could i could understand being thro
like if
my child did that i'd be like you
deserve to be expelled for that right
you could have genuinely killed someone
i i'm all about having a good time
but you could have killed someone with
that oh man you can't do that this is
this guy his name was dr
caltobiano he was a speech teacher
he used to be an actor and he was in a
couple of bit movies one with jane fonda
that was his big claim to fame
this guy was very old school he used to
come in like
cowboy boots really tight like polyester
pants
he almost looked like i want to try and
he looked like a cat
he looked like a character from like a
70s sitcom he had glasses
he had he had a little afro he always
wore a suit that was like
with a big knotted tie do you think he's
still with us has he passed
uh well i was in school 30 i mean 1990
he came in 92 i don't know he probably
was 50 at that
time he still might still be with us he
could be he was cool but he was like
the kids took advantage of him big time
and he'd walk in and he'd speak very
properly because his speech
and he'd be like mr volkat and and he
had this like accent and and everyone
realized that we could like
kind of take it like take advantage of
them and there's this one kid that used
to
uh in between classes his locker was two
lockers away from the door
that of the room and he used to come and
pound on the door
and uh and everyone did this to this guy
this poor guy everyone knew to pound on
the door and then run
right and he'd be like he would ignore
it for a couple months and then he'd be
like and then he tried to get him he'd
run to the door and swing it open
and look both ways and be like and come
back and be like i'm sorry about that
and then and then he hit her again he'd
be like in class he'd be like god damn
it
which you really weren't supposed to
like yeah and then he'd go give me one
second and he runs the door to swing it
open and be like
god damn it and and and then he you'd
see him like it was the doors had like
little windows in him yeah
and you just see him running one way and
then running the other day you guys
would be
dying dying then he'd go get another
teacher and they'd
come in and see anyone know and he'd go
back in and then
and then my one friend would do it all
the time he'd bang and then the doc
would be like hold on one second he runs
the door he swing it open and my friend
was right there
right there in his locker he was the one
doing it and he goes dr calpiano we went
that way
he would just take off he would take off
and run run down the thing and he did it
to him every time and he never
well one kid came in one time we had to
have speeches written
and he wasn't repaired and uh he was a
twin
and i forget what his name was i think
it might have been tim
and he gets in front of the class and
everyone knew he didn't have a speech we
just
the teacher was clueless and he goes he
goes mister
you know whatever give your speech and
he's like yeah and
the kids sort of in the class and just
goes my speech is about
the pros and cons of eating chalk
they just turned around and took the
chalk off the board and just started
chewing on the chalk
and eating it and like it was definitely
like
he just did that in the moment to make
up 78 he had nothing prepared and it was
he killed with it he killed us yeah but
like
the doctor to counsel beyond watching
for a couple of seconds
and and then he was just and then he he
realized that like
i think he was trying to figure out if
it was real right because i don't think
he should like come down on him if it
was real
yeah but then after two seconds he just
he just threw him out threw him out and
said get out
but see like that's fun stuff like this
is there a movie called
clute with jane fonda if so that's it
just came to me that's the movie
ot kl yeah that's it okay
yeah he was in this movie
so if you go to the cast list maybe i'll
find him in there
caltobiano was his name clute imdb
i don't know if he had like an actual
like big role but
and i think we we confirmed it but
is there anything in there that says
caltobiano how do you spell it c-a-l-t
oh that was close cola more uh okay keep
going
uh uh i might have had such a little
party
maybe he did oh my god he talked about
it like he won an oscar though
i couldn't i couldn't because you're in
my high school i don't know if it was
the same as yours my high school if i if
you didn't show up
by eight say school story at 8 30 if you
weren't there by 8 45 and there was no
note
from your mom or parent no call your
parents would be called immediately
and you'd be found out immediately there
was no way any time during the day
same thing there was no way to cut it
was impos you could but your parents
would be notified
immediately and you got indefinite
detention yes
indefinite did they call detention jug
in your school there was one teacher who
was always like you have
jug and i was like what like and i'm
like it's it's detention no i didn't
mind
merit you have to stand no you would go
in a room and you'd have to stand for
physical torture yeah yeah
did you have demerits no like merit was
like
you didn't go straight to detention like
you get it i think you got three
demerits then you got detention yeah
attention was staying at the school
for an hour yeah no we would get we
would get detention our detention was if
you got detention archbishop malloy
you had to stand in a room before school
and after school
that was one detention so it would be
two hours oh they really tried to
determine so nobody was
did you still have people acting out oh
my god of course people were just in
detention
because you would get detention if you
wore two earrings you or if you had an
earring if you had if you had one
you were allowed one earring and if you
wore two but but you could only have one
that's ridiculous what a ridiculous
thing but if you had to
let you wear one but if you have two you
have to stay before and after school and
the second one would have to be in your
pocket or in your book pick if you
you know a lot of people used to pin it
to their collar or pin it to their tie
that counted as on your person
detention oh who are they george
steinbrenner unbelievable with all those
rules
yeah no detention does
not do any no detention does not do any
good because
he's saying oh because you're saying
when kids are in detention they actually
like it
they tell me some teachers are fun and
while in detention they don't have to do
any work most of the time after the
attention they probably do what they did
again to get them into detention
if they enjoyed the teacher so i think
what they're basically saying is
is what we've gotten away from here in
this country and just in life in general
probably all over the world
is the only thing that really works is
if you beat your children
[Laughter]
[Music]
so um is j will you hit your kids is
jugg a thing
is jugg beat the [ __ ] out of my seven
day all today
she's fighting logan paul next week
yeah something yeah derived from the
latin
sub juggum meaning under a burden
okay dogs is funny you know like jugs
jugs it's a funny word
you said like when you were young in
high school you know you're talking
about a woman's breast would you say she
has jugs big melons knockers
what would you say like in high school
i'm not saying today sure i don't know
if i've used i use those words
i don't know if i said like i think i
would i think because i used to remember
saying like
you know like i remember my friend had a
girlfriend and she had like you know
like the biggest boobs in the
neighborhood
we would say she has jugs or sometimes
my friend shawn would say that girl has
pillows
[Laughter]
we we adhere to breasts for um
we adhere to the word breasts for
anything non-human humans have
like a million different things for
breasts we say different
but like like we don't you know you
won't walk in a kfc but like let me get
a bucket of chicken titties
by the way what's what's the email again
gmail.com email heybaypod gmail.com a
video of you walking into kfc
saying hey can i get an order of chicken
titties email it to hey babe
and then yeah babe as you're being
thrown out or escorted out by the police
go thursdays and for the babes and film
the whole thing
and you will get a chance we'll we'll
invite you on the show virtually
i also wanted to show you guys this kid
with the biggest mouth on the earth the
biggest mountain
like for real you mean physically
biggest mountain like i mean this kid's
got a big mouth
uh you'll see okay oh
how is his jaw doing that no wow
how does he do this when he first opened
that i was like
i did not think that was gonna
how so the kid says most people can't
open their mouth two inches
this kid's i mean god he has a baseball
in his mouth
uh should i go grab a baseball and see
if we could do this
look at how much room he's got above the
lemon's nipple
he's putting the lemon in his mouth long
ways he hooks the coke can in his mouth
i mean he could have fit another coke in
there i mean this kid
as soon as he turns 18 he's got to get
an only fan
the baseball goes in with room to spare
you could put two baseballs in there oh
is it twins baseball too he's a
minnesota kid hello a minnesota
wow wow so it so what kid has to come on
the pod
we got we got it uh we gotta get out of
him we gotta go what we'll do is we'll
take bets on what could get in his mouth
or not yes
can we reach out to this kid if you know
this kid
tell him that we want to say we want to
celebrate we want this kid on the pod
and of course if you know kane tanaka
also let her know she needs to come on
she needs to come on but this kid he has
to come on the pond and then we
we have to see if he can put the side in
his mouth it's like his
jaw unhinged he's like a snake it looks
i was going to say it looks like a snake
wow jesus it's whitney listen you know
he could use it and we could also when
he comes in we'll give him a haircut
yeah yeah really i think i i mean no
sideburns
no offense but put some pert in that
thing
these guys wow i love this kid
oh my god i mean i mean if you're him
though you're just
obsessed with seeing what will or will
not fit in your mouth
it's i'm just walking around just
literally trying to to fit things
it's one of those things where like it
is such an unbelievable talent but it's
like
what do you do like you know you're 18
nights you've got to run a date with a
girl you're striking out
everything you're saying it's not
working do you just go look what i can
do and then go
and then see if that works and then does
she go check please yeah
really well like i'm saying like would
that be something that you would bring
up
on a date like this is my talent or you
can't really
i i i wonder what that feels like it's
got to be bad because it's
my mouth does not even open i mean could
you imagine the first time he got strep
throat and the doctor said open your
mouth let me see
he was like wow okay hello fresh is one
of these things where it's like
i changed my life i have it i have so
it's like yeah there's ad copy there's
things too but it doesn't matter
because you know what i know that
they're doing now yeah it used to be
you would get 12 free meals with the
promo code yeah now it's 14
free meals no it's not yes it is dude
this company is going insane
you're giving away so much fun meals is
more free meals than anyone's ever given
me now they bumped it up to 14 14 now
because hello fresh first of all it's 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store and 72 percent cheaper
than a restaurant meal without
sacrificing the quality
all the ingredients delivered to your
door ready to go you can make meals in
30 minutes or less
yes literally hello fresh is quick and
easy meals 15 to 20 minute meals
you're literally i know how to cook now
because of hello fresh and i've been
cooking for my family cooking for myself
and it's the food is unbelievable high
quality fresh ingredients sourced
directly
directly from growers and showers and
delivered from the farm to your front
door in
under a week contact free of course that
means there's no covid on the food
that's right that's right and if you
have a long day at work who wants to
come home
and stop at the grocery store first and
pick out ingredients who wants to figure
that all out it's ready for you to go
as soon as you come home that's what i
like about it be an
absolute if you did not go
to hellofresh.com
14 and use code hey babe 14
for up to 14 free meals plus free
shipping they're giving you
14 meals for free plus free shipping
you're robbing these people you're
robbing these people hello fresh is
going to go into business
because they're giving away so much free
food we need to have a conference call
the people at hella fresh the deals are
too good
i mean where are they located the north
pole these people
slash hey babe hellofresh.com used to
code hey babe 14. america's
number one meal kid
[Music]
damn damn i'm trying to think of how he
can monetize
what that is is there he clearly was
born he must be
i'm again taking a chance he must be
born he must be missing
a part of his anatomy that he can do
that you think so you think something
against what i think the
logical explanation has to be on why he
can do it unless
he does some kind of exercise look at
his mom his mom's trying to get in on
the
i mean his mom was like what kind of
thing did i create oh my god he's got a
tick tock
i'm telling you right now he's putting
the soda can in his mouth
and there is room for about another soda
can easily
i mean because it's one of those things
like this is fun and cool because he's
12. but once you get a little older
you're like
all right can we take that as an old man
he's going to be terrifying terrifying
imagine the kids ring his bell for
trick-or-treating and he opens doors
i love this that's how he monetizes
horror movies audition for horror movies
is that
he should right oh i think he should we
should literally get him on the show and
see what pieces of the podcast equipment
he can fit in his mouth
like could he put pimp's soundboard in
his mouth could he put the 4k camera in
his mouth
i i i i i will have him on we let's do
it i'd love to have him on there we can
reach him he's got to take
isaac johnson or maybe we get him on
zoom and we just we just we just place
bets on what
what objects are yeah that'll be a fun
zoom game you can do with us do you
think he's been asked to do this
i mean at a party like people are
inviting him to parties just for his
mouth yeah but how do you feel now that
he hasn't
done a good personality but like they're
like you gotta invite
what's his name isaac you gotta invite
isaac yeah the thing is though i'm sure
he has a great personality but and i
would love to talk to him and get to
know him but it really any conversation
would just be
kind of just being polite to get to all
right open your mouth and let's put
things put objects in your mouth
now what world record would you want to
be known for like this like a party
trick
world record
i'd like um party trick like that like
open the mouth of the kid who can count
to 100 the quickest
the kid who can count 100 let's see if
he can put the kid who can count to 100
quickest in his mouth
[Laughter]
should we do that
if you uh if you were dating a girl and
then um
you didn't know that about her and you
were like months in let me just then all
of a sudden she opened her mouth the
size of a bear trap
would you would that affect anything i
will say this
it's probably a guy a girl
doing that i how do i say this
maybe don't say it okay this has been
hey
we at we got no we got like 10 minutes
what um what were you going to say like
say like tip tip
handles care okay
i'll say like i mean i'm talking about
let's say all parties are
in their 20s a girl opening her mouth
like that
would be you know more guys would be
more interested in a girl opening her
mouth like that
then girls would be interesting in a guy
opening his mouth like that that's what
else that's what i'm trying to say
you know what i mean yeah because even
though a girl opening her mouth like
that means
nothing i mean so what am i gonna wha
what does that do okay so i can put my
penis scrotum and both legs in your
mouth i mean what does it matter
what am i gonna camp in your mouth but
i'm just saying
but but i'm just saying you know how
good this girl is gonna be like he put
the whole titty in his mouth right
exactly like what what does that do for
them
but i bet you he's been asked to do that
well wait he's a kid right yeah yeah
he's a kid all right so he
will be he has to do it he hasn't been
asked but look forward to it look
forward to it
how about this july well today is july
1st this episode
when is this episode coming out i mean
mid july mid july okay oh wow so this
episode isn't even coming out next week
no oh well so i'm wearing the fourth of
july shirt and the fourth of july was
weeks ago
so so yeah so if you're watching this i
blew off both my hands in the fireworks
accident and uh
i'm now a lobster um um it's july first
oh yeah today which one but it means
that it's meant it's bobby bonilla day
yeah you know about this right i do
buy one of your day which is if you guys
don't know if you're if you're not a
mets fan or baseball fan you just don't
know about this contract
um bobby bonilla who used to play for
the new york mets
got a contract i forgot what the actual
totality of the
total number of money in the contract
was but instead of getting it paid out
over the course of three four years like
a normal person
he decided to get 1.19
million dollars a year every year until
2035 when he'll be 72 years old
and he hasn't played in 20 years he
hasn't played in 20 years so he took
he took the money over the course of i
believe 35 years
yes
which is kind of cheap it's genius
though
that is wild how funny is it though i
would take that
what would you do if because he had
because the reason why he did that is he
already had signed a big contract
years before he already had money okay
he's like instead of just getting
you know a bunch of money yeah like when
you're in the lottery you take the cash
payment up front or you do the annual i
would do annual
yeah what would you do i go up front i
want all that liquidity working for me
immediately
but i don't want to leave it up to
chance i'll take the money i'll invest
it i'll do whatever i need to do with it
i want the lump sum now because anything
can happen anything can happen babe
yep yeah um yeah speaking of anything
can happen if you go to
christiecomedy.com i'm back on the road
i got a lot of stand up dates coming up
we just added tickets you ready for this
we just added tickets to philadelphia
providence and boston all those shows
were sold out but now philadelphia
providence and boston if you live in
those cities christy comedy.com
where the tickets are there and then we
got nashville uh we got
eatontown new jersey we got fox theater
foxwoods in october
so all the tickets there but
philadelphia providence boston added
tickets go get em
christy comedy.com for all my stand up
dates babe very nice very nice
i have uh in two weeks from now uh well
actually probably around when this comes
out
uh we have a big announcement a big
joker's announcement about our tour
uh which is in place and about to be
announced
and then uh i'm working on solo tour now
although i think i'm going to be doing
an austin date
september 24th there we go and then one
day we had talked about this right
before the pandy wendy
sal and i had talked about going on a
little tour through the uk
we obviously can't do it anytime soon
but
we should start thinking about 20 22-ish
whenever you're done with the joker's
throwing your solo stuff
me and you through the uk with the pimp
i would love that because we were
talking we were talking about we would
just go
go ahead and do it yeah we could do
stand-up and the pod stand up in the
pond in the uk i want to do it that'd be
real for you okay yeah
uh uk peeps if you're watching let us
know yeah we know that and also and also
thursday shout out uk shout out uk by
the way shout out to the united kingdom
shout out to delta variant
yeah um you shout out delta airlines
shout out delta ellen
that's why i fly america because i got
the delta has the vehicle shout out uk
the country and the letters
and the letters shout out kingdoms in
general yeah shout out united airlines
yeah shout out you know yeah shout out
everybody outlines
shout out to the white line shout out
yeah shout out to
you know the north sea um ready for this
also
how about this thursdays in general your
thursdays just got better because you
already have thursdays hey babe 11am
eastern time
now for the next 10 oh it's on it
started last week it started last week
every thursday now you keep it you keep
it locked on true tv 10 o'clock you got
in practical jokers
10 30 you got my show backyard bar wars
and thursdays at 11 a.m you got the both
of us so it's like thursdays we have you
on lockdown now
it's christine style thursdays that's
what it is that's what it is
t-i-l-t-g-i-t's
t-g-i-t-t jerrys there you go t-g-i-t-t
jerry's
oh another thing hey bay pod hey hey
babe potter gmail.com
we are making the merch we're in the
middle of sourcing ideas
we want to know from you hey babepod
gmail.com tell us what you want to see
the merch on
and tell us what you want to see merch
of your favorite little quips
sayings this so that's inside jokes you
want it on a thong
you want it on a flip-flop you want it
on you know you want it on a potato
whatever you want just
give us your ideas we we have our own
but we want to see
what the resounding feedback is and who
knows maybe we'll
we'll see your idea and we'll we'll
think it's good enough to make them love
it on the potato
i'd love yeah not enough people do do
merch on food i think we got to do that
i know we did it with the peanut butter
now i like to move in the potatoes
uh two years ago i think it was i sent
uh there was a service
that i saw online that sent people a
potato with a message on it
and so for christmas i sent casey jost
just a
potato and they inscribed they inscribed
they wrote on it for me casey jost
the best person go follow him on
instagram at casey jones i believe
right yep i've never seen a guy look
better with with gray hair than casey
jose
pulls off gray hair better than richard
gere yeah yeah better he's the new
richard gear it's a new clooney okay
he's a new clooney oh casey richard gear
should stick casey joe's up his ass
that's exactly right instead of gerbils
gerbils
because you know that story uh yeah i
don't know if it's true or not
yeah but that's everybody thinks richard
here thinks the gerbils up his butt
yeah yeah yeah you know the story no i
have i don't know the the
the details surrounding it like he walks
around with a gerbil no
some story like somebody caught him
putting gerbils up his butt or he got a
gerbil delivery to his house one day and
the fedex guy said he saw
the gerbil hanging out of his butt
something like that some story sounds
who knows if it's true or not highly
questionable cultural history of richard
gere's ass gerbil but is gerbil in the
ass a thing for real in general
yes that i always thought was gotta be
fake too
dude when i was a physical therapist
when i was a physical therapist
yeah i saw the sickest
dude guy comes in south listen to me
jeremy
comes in no not gerbilling or gerbil
stuffing or gerbil shooting
yeah is an actual practice of inserting
small live animals
usually gerbils but also mice hamsters
rats and other rodents
into the human rectum to obtain
stimulation some variations of reports
suggest that the rodent
be covered in psychoactive substance
such as cocaine
psychoactive substance such as cocaine
prior to be inserted
for the patreon market will you do it
i would do it you wouldn't do it so i
would do it would you do it
that that's all we need for patreon you
get a rodent you rub it up here
and all the tears come on it's just that
one video just don't want me to come by
so okay so i'm a physical therapist
right guy comes in excruciating back
pain we're doing every trick
in the book every trick in the book we
cannot like he pulled an ace out of us
they're doing everything we're doing
we're trying so hard we're literally
everything i you could imagine this test
that test called in the
the the the my boss who's got 30 years
practice we cannot
find out we cannot find out why this guy
has excruciating like back pain
and we're asking all these questions
we're saying sir sir
what what did you do like what is it he
goes i swear i heard it lifting weights
and we're saying we've done every test
that would indicate
lifting weights you know if you if you
heard of lifting weights these tests
would have reproduced the pain
by now and we would have figured out 100
what is going on in your back
so yes you want to guess are we taking
guesses so we finally hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on because it's
mind-blowing okay so when we finally
when we finally
actually i'm talking about everybody
comes in orthopedic surgeon came into
because the the physical therapy clinic
we were at was like you ran through the
whole practice
what was a whole it was a whole like
health care building so we had the
orthopedic surgeon was down the hall
so the physical therapist couldn't
figure it out orthopedic surgeon could
not figure it out
we brought in um a special there was a
specialized back surgeon couldn't figure
out
a plastic surgeon the person who did
plastic surgery on j wow the guy who
gave jay wow
her new jugs he he couldn't figure it
out she got new detentions
she got new detentions so we don't know
what to do so finally we say the only
thing left to do is we have to bring in
an x-ray machine
we bring this guy into he is literally
he's like i don't want to do an x-ray i
don't want to do that if you want the
pain to go away
then you'll do the x-ray we put him and
we're all there because it's all our
patient now people just want to know
we put this guy underneath the x-ray
machine and this has been abandoned
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings bae don't be
afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey